[Applause]
[Music]
I I know I'm excited I'm so excited um
wait okay so wait I'm going to first
start with um the holidays are here you
look beautiful and red by the way this
is a color I'm really trying to ground
myself CU I'm looking into your eyes and
this is so cool oh my God same and I
literally and I was so excited cuz last
night I was like reading up I always do
like my homework before I because I know
things about like your work but I don't
I never like the person knows personal
thing I I'll work oh my go I oh my god
well I have seen everything you're in I
saw from Justin to Kelly the day it came
out oh my God that's a real fan okay is
not good um I I never we're going to get
into that acting versus singing but
before we get there like for the
holidays do you get into this are you I
feel like I I know I was reading up on
you I feel like we're you love giving
gifts I love giving gifts thoughtful too
started I'm like a month in already I
usually start in October yeah yeah yeah
because I feel like it starts to come
you start to see things and you go oh I
should get that for this person and why
wait and if you wait it all of a sudden
everything hits you and you have no time
exactly and I also like to wrap my
presence me too really well me too yes I
make all the tags it's a whole thing
people offer to do it and I'm offended
I'm like no you're going to run it yeah
yeah I do the like bits and bobles I do
tag I do everything I have a theme every
year it's a thing it's a thing this year
I think I'm going with just solid
parchment like CL with with twine cuz
usually yes brown paper package color no
I did that a couple years ago love you
so much we should be friends yes okay
let's do it so I also heard you did
something random like I would do as well
and have done in different countries um
but so when I go to Country I I really
inspired by the surroundings and you
went and you were in the presence of
people looming right in France that oh
yeah yeah yes and then you ended up
buying a l yes i' yes I've decided I'm a
textile artist now yes but it's kind of
fun to try new things oh it's the best
it mean it's the spice of life really
yes I saw quilt that I loved in some
antique thing I was like I could do this
I don't do it well but I do it it
doesn't matter that's not the point I
get so much joy out of it yeah so what
other things have you tried oh my gosh
I've tried so many things I mean this
started when I was a kid I was like all
kinds of dance lessons and drawing
lessons and and tennis and um oh gosh
everything I skating figure skating was
my thing for a while skating yeah and
then like now as time's gone on it's
like I'm rock climbing or I'm doing
or now I'm like I'm a textile artist
everyone's like okay let's give this six
months see I don't have a friendly all
my friends are different from me not one
is um kind of crazy and likes everything
like you do too me too I don't have that
friend me too why not even if you suck
at it it's fun just to try you get one
life it's fun to know and there was a
year this ended up being exhausting so I
tried this out don't do it where I
wouldn't order anything at a restaurant
that I hadn't made
myself yeah what I thought it would be
fun it's not what do you mean I don't I
don't understand couldn't order lasagna
at a restaurant until I learned how to
make lasagna oh yes so I would do
everything it forced me to try but yeah
yeah I would I don't cook well this is
the one thing I learned about you that
we are yeah I I'm going to show you how
to do that here's the thing I can cook I
can I don't like it I I can I can make
breakfast I can make lunch I can do
dinner I can do it I hate it why unless
people are in the kitchen with me I'm
just in there by myself and then my kids
hate it anyway whatever I make and I'm
just like yeah that's why I like it's
exhausting I love it I can I'm
supporting the economy via Postmates
yeah that's great yeah every restaurant
these people need money so I'm helping
that it's very helpful everybody doing
their job and then everybody can get
what you want like I just gave up I used
to be that person that felt like I was a
failure as a mom if unless I was cooking
it but they don't freaking eat it so I'm
like I'm exhausted after work and I'm
like you're going to eat the pasta and
they don't so anyway supp postmes it is
I know I really wish I I like baking
though but baking is fun yeah baking
chemistry it's it's well we're going to
get there I didn't even mean to do that
I didn't even mean to do it no but it's
because I like it precise yeah that's
part of why baking is not totally my
thing because you really have to follow
directions and I'm not good at that oh
my God I need you tell me I'm not like a
rules girly I'm like a let's just throw
things together and make it happen yeah
I do that when cooking and then it's not
edible yeah yes that's a thing I think
that we love this though you love hot
dogs and I love hot dogs I do love hot
dogs yes I do yeah why when did this
start this passion um oh gosh yeah when
did my love affair with the hot dog
begin well I've always loved hot dogs
but my best friend Courtney McBroom who
was also the food consultant on um oh
yeah you can see it right there and
lessons and chemistry yeah food
consultant on lessons and chemistry she
started she's the president of the hot
dog appreciation club and I'm a proud
member obviously nice um yes and so this
is segued into um a hot dog appreciation
Festival that's once a year at my
family's house my stepdad dresses as a
hot dog um it's a lot um but it's a it's
a really great it's super fun oh yeah
you can see it all going down so I hear
you have a debate with that Fanny Pat
get it um I hear there's a debate yeah
but if if a sandwich if the hot dog is a
sandwich or if it's separate if it's a
hot dog it's not I think a hot dog is a
hot dog I think to say that it is a
sandwich is blasphemy um but Courtney
thinks that it's a sandwich and it's
very hard to argue with someone who is
the president of the hot dog
appreciation Club it's like why am I
fighting reality I don't know it's kind
of fun do you know what's funny is I
don't I've never thought about it maybe
y'all have but I've never thought about
but it is bread with meat in between I
know but it's connected
and that makes all the
difference okay okay okay okay okay okay
but what about a Subway sandwich like a
s you know that's a sub is connected am
I blowing your mind right now it's not
connected it's not connected it's not
connected it's super I want to see
toally show hands how many people I
won't be offended I'm just curious how
many people think a hot dog is a
sandwich see the people who say alone
are emphatic that it's a no and we don't
even really know why but it's just wrong
but I'm very proud of the like five
people that stood strong in their belief
yes thank you you stood with me we were
alone on an island but it's okay I never
thought about it before and then I was
like well it kind of is like a sub
sandwich St provoking yeah not provoking
for sure stop provoking you can see her
now in lessons in chemistry on Apple TV
plus and in the Marvels which is in
theaters right now I love all the things
you do what I found crazy though is that
you're singing and dancing in the new
Marvels yeah we can talk about that now
finally I know like it's were you
excited about that I was thrilled I the
whole time when I first read this SC I
was like they're not going to let me
actually do this but they did they did
and it was a lot of work we had to
rehearse for like a month um James
Murphy of LCD sound system did the music
and it was incredible absolutely
incredible and it's so it's like because
it's one of the places that you go and
they all sing yes it's a planet where
their language is in song so that's they
don't know they can't hear anything
unless it's my Planet it's yeah it's
really fun I would love Planet you
actually released an album as a teen
which I did not know and found out
that's probably for the best well you
saw all from Justin M Kelly so that's
probably not the best but we all have
our things but no but what what kind of
style was it it was I mean it was Pop I
played guitar I wrote the songs um you
like writing though you enjoy writing
you still write yeah
love wowers yeah finally out of PE yeah
that's not see and these are reasons why
15 year-old shouldn't have albums you
know or why they should that or yeah or
maybe they should I even look back at
myself St and I'm like I always say I
should make an album like better with
age and like recut things cuz you're
just babies right and your voice isn't
like gr you know you whatever you don't
know what you're doing or I didn't know
what I was do I should say that but it
was I mean it was really fun it was just
a strange thing that happened I still
can't believe that that happened a lot
of actors sing though like a lot of
actors that come to the show I didn't
really know that before doing the show
but a lot of people are like in bands or
were in bands and they're always like I
don't do anym I'm like whatever I was
like you love you I think it's awesome
to be creative like that totally you
should sing with me when tell on the
show just like
okay um well let's talk about lessons in
chemistry speaking of that my literally
my recent album was called chemistry and
I was in a bookstore buying for books
for my kids and I was on my way out and
it was like sitting right there and it
said lessons in chemistry this was like
a while back and I was like well this is
a sign I should buy this book so I
started reading it yeah and then now
it's like a show so I'm so excited show
have you read the book before yeah I got
the book about two years before it was
released so it's been like my little
secret for a while and now it's been
just amazing to see it out in the world
and doing so well yeah mhm it's such a
cool uh it's just such a cool idea and
how back in the day how women had to
kind of pivot and navigate yes you know
it deals with that quite a bit I love it
it's be a good work and you are you a
foodie like you are in the show oh yes
definitely I mean I spend most of my
time if I'm not on set I'm cooking
that's just what I do I'm very
comfortable in the kitchen I really want
to be your friend cuz then I'll just eat
yeah you can you can explain the show
and the book to everybody that does know
sure so the the book and the and the
show is based on this character around
this character Elizabeth zot and she is
a chemist um who is not able to do her
passions because um you know sexism is a
thing um and so she ends up needing to
do a quick detour from the thing that
she loves and gets a job as a as a TV
show host for a cooking show um and she
fuses her love of science and chemistry
with food um and becomes this big
sensation because she talks to
Housewives as if they are smart capable
individuals um and so it kind of just is
tracking her in her life um it's a
really really really beautiful story it
says a lot about life um the Journey of
Life how it's unexpected um and hard and
beautiful all at the same time yeah I
just like that it's unexpected that you
do something like I never would have
thought I would done this job but I love
that it's unexpected and you still can
kind of incorporate things that you love
into it and I think that people should
be open-minded about that oh yes cuz
sometimes we get stuck in our things and
you seem like a person that like once
you finish an acting job you're like
maybe I should Skydive like oh yeah
definitely I'm also like I should I
don't know if I'll ever do that again
that's what I'm saying you're like wait
I've done this so I like to keep
changing it up too I think that's the
thing is like then I find kills me yeah
I have to change it up and then I always
end up finding a way back to acting but
like for right now I've been I've T
taken pretty much a year off and all
I've done is dance like that's the main
I've been doing like six hours a day of
dance L what kind um a lot of ballet but
other things too I've been doing tap now
see did you relate it all to the
character oh yes very much so definitely
the food part yeah I mean of course
there's always things that I'm like oh I
have to understand that better like I
just am not innately as smart in science
and chemistry as she is so that was I
had to learn about that but in terms of
like a woman with a passion trying to
make her way through like of of course
and also the way that you know we try
our best to quantify life and set
ourselves up for success but there's
just things that are unexpected things
that happen and um I've of course had
times in my life where I've been like I
don't understand why this is happening
and then in time it reveals itself why
and that life somehow organizes itself
in a really spectacular way yeah wow you
should write a book you're good at this
oh maybe I'll do that next yeah I was
like you should write a book yeah never
done that right try that no yeah you
have a very great way of putting things
that are very relatable but elevated
it's nice okay so were you good in
science at school I mean I was yeah I'm
competitive so I want to be good at
everything but I'm not like I'm
competitive and I'm not good at science
I was always way more interested in the
Arts like any class that was like we're
going to do a project I would like hone
in on that and they'd be like okay we
just wanted like a tiny little thing
you've made a diarama and you didn't do
the rest of your work and like what's
going on it's just very clear what I
wanted to do yes um are you ready for a
game then I thought we cuz we're both
competitive okay okay let's do all right
lessons in chemistry is on Apple TV plus
you've got to check it out everybody and
the Marvels is in theaters now which is
also equally
[Music]
[Applause]
incredible thank you guys y'all have a
great night I'm going home